[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
is it finally over have we finally
reached the expiration date of the
Russia gate conspiracy hoax probably not
my definition conspiracy theorists are
never satisfied but a few things are for
sure confidence in government has taken
a hit and the reputation of the media
may never be redeemed
[Music]
raaah stocking Russia gate I'm joined by
my guests here in Moscow Dmitry Babak
he is a political analyst with Sputnik
International in London we crossed
Alexander makiura sea as a writer on
legal affairs as well as the
editor-in-chief of the Durand calm and
in New York we have Don debar he's an
anti-war activist and host of a daily
radio program
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means he can jump in any
time you want and I always appreciate it
Alexander Macarius let me go to you in
London a happy note collusion day I
think we'll make it an official holiday
all right but you know you wrote to me
earlier this is the biggest fishing
expedition that caught no fish at all
except for and we'll talk about it with
the Dimitri Babak it still Russia's
fault that's what the report says
Alexander Matthias you have a great
legal mind
can you just sum it up if possible I
know you read the report last night
go ahead yes I read the report it I
found it relentlessly hostile to Donald
Trump in a way that I actually I found
slightly shocking you have the first
part of the report in which a mother and
his team look at follow up every a
suggestion of contacts between the
Russians and the Donald Trump campaign
and you get almost a sense of
disappointment when they repeatedly come
up with nothing and then the second part
of the report is an extraordinary
academic exercise I should say a flawed
academic exercise in my opinion in which
outbursts of anger on the part of an
innocent man yes to say Donald Trump are
construed as some sort of attempt at
obstruction even though there is
actually no attempt to impede Mahler and
his team in doing anything and none of
the threats that Donald Trump talks
about from time to time about sacking
Muller ever actually amount to anything
so I mean I I found it him actually a
rather disturbing document that the
important boy to get back to get to
understand is it even this extremely
aggressive very hostile team of
investigators
clearly out to find something against
Donald Trump and to create some kind of
collusion narrative or in the end unable
to do so and they can't even
convincingly construct an obstruction
narrative either
deema but it's it's also clear in the
report that Russia is culpable to one
degree or another they're pretty murky
and talking about connections to
WikiLeaks and then they're the parts
that that have to do with GRU that's
what they call the Russian agents is
redacted so it's pretty much a mystery
right there but it's it's very leading
isn't it go ahead Dima well not only the
part about GRU is redacted there is a
whole page devoted to yevgeniy
precaution that since the cook from the
Kremlin Code viously the American
election and you only have the name
you've gained Ypres version there and
the rest of the page is just blackened
so it was hilarious to read it but I
think even more hilarious you know for
the Financial Times has the list of the
cases of Russian involvement in the
election and I'm just going to quote it
because I can't quote of course the
whole report but it's it's pretty much
it's pretty precise so these Russian
efforts consisted in invitations for
campaign officials and representatives
of the Russian government to meet
invitations for candidate Trump and
Putin to meet in person and this is the
most awful thing policy positions
seeking improved us-russian relations
all full you know although and the
biggest crime I mentioned in this report
is that curio dmitry f you know the head
of russian agency for direct investment
he's got an order from President Putin
to seek reconciliation with the United
States so this is just awful and the
report says you know they they obviously
listen to some of mr. meteors
conversations and he called Putin the
boss you know a Russian state official
called Putin the boss he is a criminal
obviously you know so
the United States doesn't have to worry
about getting involved in the wars in
Libya in Iraq Afghanistan this is not
important what is important is that he
called Putin the boss and he wanted to
improve Russia US relations okay now I
come down this is taxpayers dollars at
work here I mean this is trivial
I mean it's worse than trivial because
it really showed the what we'll find out
to what degree the government tried to
and did invent all of this against
Donald Trump I mean with that team that
Muller had and it's a expense account
and they give us this dribble go ahead
Don it's worth a lot worse if he if he
ponder what when Dmitri just said and
and then read further into the say just
into the executive portion of the thing
where they do interpretation one of one
of the it like self proves itself that
the Kremlin had motive to do this thing
because they felt that Trump would have
a more favorable foreign policy towards
Russia than Clinton would well you know
Clinton's foreign policy could be
deduced from the foreign policy that was
in place while she was Secretary of
State when her husband was president and
well the Obama administration was in
power which is the movement of troops
and material up to Russia's borders
while they war gained from the Baltics
and Korean Peninsula to me that looks
extremely intimidating and someone that
would recommend that there was some
other way of engaging between the US and
Russia suddenly that's evidence of a
crime or of a mindset for a crime rather
than sanity I mean that all by itself
isn't even subtle and it's a frightening
thought but in terms of proof what they
were referring to both Andrew and
Dimitri you have a situation in there
where it's it's akin to saying Hillary
Clinton prefers to sleep with goats we
have photographs see exhibit a and you
go to exhibit a and it says you know
redact redact buzz it means ok elegant
Alexander
it's really quite amazing if you watch
like CNN and MSNBC it is it is as if the
last two and a half years didn't happen
because now it's all about obstruction I
mean there's no reflection there's no
inward looking how they botched this I
mean fueled it on could help create this
this hoax that is very dangerous for
international affairs I mean but you
know but we've seen we're in a new Cold
War I mean that's and it's because of
all of this and then something that was
completely invented out of nothing so
now it's obstruction gate we're gonna
get two more years of that I'm sick and
tired of this story no evidence stop it
and it's move on go ahead in London uh
but on the obstruction I absolutely
agree with you I mean I personally think
that he's going to be impossible to
substantiate or sustain this obstruction
argument for any length of time I say
that because though what mother and his
people have done is that they've paddy
eating all out with very very
complicated legal arguments full of
citation of cases all intended to make
it look very impressive in reality I
think anybody who understands this area
of the law can see right through it very
very fast the fact is there was no
underlying crime I mean that's
absolutely clear if you look at the
first part of the report the second part
is Donald Trump was clearly an innocent
man throughout knew he was an innocent
man and thirdly he didn't actually do
anything I mean he threatened and talked
and stormed and thundered about it but
nothing actually happened because he
would give instructions to various
people that he would refuse to carry
them out because I'm pretty sure they
knew that they weren't to be taken
seriously and in the end Donald Trump
pulls back and mother goes on unimpeded
and gets everything he asks for there's
apparently no use of executive privilege
to withhold things from him he
is able to see everything he's able to
do everything he gets answers and Donald
Trump that he doesn't really like but
you know that's Donald Trump's privilege
as somebody under interrogation and you
know at the end of the day
you simply can't see obstruction here
there's no real evidence of it so I
think if the Democrats and the media
want to fly with this one they're just
not going to get anywhere with it
because I do think the American people
are going to be at all interested in
something that never happened yeah it's
I think that never happened to put to
conceal a conspiracy which didn't exist
deema it is it's really the the highest
level of being in denial because if the
underlying narrative main is maintained
that Russia well we don't know exactly
what it did and we can't really show you
but it's their fault in a way it keeps
this ridiculous narrative going because
they have nowhere else to go because
they're not going to apologize for what
they did
deema well basically I don't want our
viewers to get an impression that we
justify everything Trump did you know
basically they hang on t-mac that's a
really good point here we could make a
lot of programs of what Donald Trump has
done wrong yes and his illegal foreign
policy we could go on and on and on
about that but this is about the rule of
law keep going thank you
actually what we're seeing is a clash
between two very bad factions I'm sorry
it's like Hitler having a conflict with
the room the crowd of stormtroopers in
1934 both Trump and his opponents were
very aggressive in their foreign
policies they they basically destroyed
several countries well Trump just didn't
destroy any new ones but he continued
the operations the so-called operations
in Syria and in many other places but
what happened is that basically we have
these these factions collation and they
use ridiculous arguments I mean from
this report the most interesting part
for me was what actually Michael Flynn
was talking about with the Russian
ambassador Sergei Keyes Larkin
we were told that this was terrible that
this was treason
you know Flynn misinformed the vice
president actually fleeing tried to talk
the Russians into vetoing
Oh postponing recursion which was good
for easy well I'm gonna jump in here
we're gonna go to a short break and
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion on the Russia Gate hoax
stay with RT welcome back to crosstalk
where all things are considered I'm
Peter LaBelle to remind you we're
discussing the Russia Gate hoax
[Music]
you know done in it nowhere in the
report that we do we learn that the the
mother people looked into the FBI not
taking a look at the DNC servers and if
and if we could get that whole issue
resolved definitively then it would take
on a very different direction but we
don't get there and it's I get the
impression that they're relying upon
CrowdStrike which is obviously a tainted
organization so one of the most
fundamental simple things to resolve was
not even looked into and not resolved go
ahead Don well first of all Alexander
had crew absolutely correct the emphasis
on the fact that this whole thing that's
taking place in front of the American
public does nothing to address the
actual concerns of the American public
they could think it care less about
Russia gate they want to know you know
where the next meals coming from and how
their rent or mortgage is going to be
paid or college tuition to the health
care and the Democrats are serving up
still Russia Gaede Muller and all of
that I think that it's very very
important to understand the significance
of the declaration by bar that he's now
going to be looking into the other side
of the coin which is you know what
you're intimating should have been done
inside of this study that is you almost
in plain view
you had a privately assembled funded by
the DNC and by one of the Republican
candidates a smear report on Trump that
was Shepherd into the FBI I used that as
the basis for a fraud in the inducement
basically on the FISA Court to get a
warrant to wiretap Trump's campaign
which put the Obama administration which
was actively campaigning for Clinton in
the position of having access through
all of trumps communications that is
something that you know makes Watergate
look pale yeah through what happened
here and that investigation is just
about to begin you know a few months out
from the beginning of the 20/20 election
so I think
that if Trump is able to satisfy the
economic concerns of enough people in
the right places you know for the
electoral college or whatever calculus
they used and amaura on this theme
through the media as much as they can
get it out I don't see how the Democrats
have a chance to win next year unless
they come across with something that
will actually satisfy people's needs
instead of more Russia Gate okay I see
Dima wants to jump in go ahead Dima yeah
well I mean the media accused Trump of
obstructing justice you know he
basically tried to obstruct
investigation of something that never
happened you know this collusion with
Russia right so that is absurd but what
we're seeing now is basically the media
obstructing justice because Barr gave
this press conference minutes before
releasing the report and all the media
lashed out at him for what for saying
that property they were going to
investigate the investigators that they
were going to find out who started the
whole collusion thing which is a very
natural move and Barr did not did not in
any way distort the essence of the
report they didn't fight they didn't
find any evidence of collusion but the
media just attacked Barr and I think it
was a classic classical case of
obstructing justice before that justice
was even announced to be served
you know Alexander Donald Trump
throughout this time period and his
lawyers called it a witch-hunt I think
the term will stay in vogue because
that's exactly what the media is good to
say is investigating the investigators
basically the Obama administration
they're gonna call that a witch-hunt and
I think they will will get still very
skewed coverage of it and Don debar is
absolutely right people are not
interested in this story they're being
forced being forced to listen to it and
to and to get involved in this political
battle that the Democrats have against
this duly elected president so Alexander
I mean the the the media and the
Democrats they they don't want the other
shoe to drop they don't want the
investigators to be investigated that's
the only part
this whole tragedy that I am interested
in because all of us on this program
found this hoax to be ridiculous from
the get-go go ahead in London what it
will indeed and I mean and Dawn is
absolutely right about this because of
course so many of the things that week I
would judge important are not actually
in the report I mean to give you an
example
Christopher steel and he's famous
dossier which played such a big role in
so many of the media stories at the back
in 2017 and which was used to obtain the
FISA warrants on Carter page it's barely
mentioned I mean you don't have an
admission for example that this report
played her any role at all in triggering
the investigation and it has been
unverified so it's as if it didn't exist
and all the many of the sort of catalog
of characters that were involved in
investigating this report in some
tangential way then only they're not
mentioned either so that of course we
need to see a proper investigation into
how this whole thing took off in the way
that it did leading to a report a four
hundred and twenty-two page report after
I mean must be tens of thousands of
hours of investigations millions of
dollars the entire political system of
the United States paralyzed foreign
policy held hostage russian-american
relations brought to crisis all to
achieve nothing nothing because there
was nothing there and that really ought
to be something people should see
looking to and of course you're
absolutely right the media will oppose
it ferociously
and I predict that the witch-hunt
allegation will now switch to the other
side though with far less justice
because there's no doubt at all
certain very unattractive things happen
you know done I watched bars testimony
in front of Congress and he said really
very clearly and with great deal of
confidence that the Trump administration
had been spied upon now I don't know if
our viewers saw the entire testimony but
it's a very ended congressman one do you
really want to change that word maybe
you want to sit into them for spying and
bar the only adult in the room and it's
refreshing to have an adult in the room
for a change because we haven't seen it
for a long long time
he said no oh you can well surveillance
spying whatever you want to call it but
we're gonna look into that we're
definitely going to look into that
I thought half the room was going to
faint because we have enough sir we have
enough evidence already in the public
realm to know that that is that exactly
what happened we just need to connect
all the dots and and have a grand jury
and start the investigation they now
it's their turn to do some talking
go ahead done well and see the
disadvantage that the perpetrators of
that face the the the the
disadvantageous position that they
occupied basically rests on the fact
that what they've done was assembled
into a sworn affidavit and submitted to
a court rather than a bunch of hearsay
and collateral references to the
computer input in st. Petersburg and
Kiev and whatever else these various
communications were supposed to take
place in other words rather than just
some amorphous allegations that can get
strung together in a timeline that looks
impressive but rests on no factual
evidence there's an affidavit sworn to
you know with note with a notary at the
end of it submitted to a court that can
be presented these people actually did
say these things to a court and here's
the court order that they received that
allow them to wiretap and here's the
wiretap these things exist in the
material world and they can be dragged
into
court room or before a congressional
committee and it can be exposed to the
world and those things am i I'm
estimating this looking at it right now
but I think I see serial felonies
they're involving a whole lot of players
including a lot of people in Congress
who've covered for it who had knowledge
of it and people in the media as well
you know deema there was a conspiracy
actually a grand conspiracy on a scale
that we've never seen before
and that was to undermine to candidate
and not in the opposition and a duly
elected president
this is far far bigger than Watergate
you know I when people say oh there's no
comparison there is a comparison and and
Watergate was a small beer okay because
this is the kegger of all conspiracies
and it's really real DEMA go ahead was I
agree with you completely but also
picking on what Alexander said about the
damage the material damage done by this
investigation it's not only thirty five
million dollars which were paid for it
officially it's not only thousands of
working hours of Jonas you know the New
York Times sent a team to Prague to find
out if one of trumps official met with
the Russian representative there and it
never happened
also don't forget there were sanctions
imposed on Russia bills right exactly a
collusion and the sanctions if we take
into account that the the slavish polish
of the European Union which also imposed
sanctions these sanctions
according to UN estimates cost about one
hundred billion dollars to the to the
Western Wall to the European Union and
of course billions of dollars to Russia
so basically it's the the damage from
all the story is huge and unfortunately
it continues you know right before the
the report was released Stephan Cohen
published a very good piece in the
nation where he singled out three
markers of lies that's what I would call
it markers of lies he hasn't yet read
the report he hadn't yet read the report
a report by that time but he said that
if the old narrative about comparing
Russia gate to
to Pearl Harbor continuous if the so
called steel dosia continues and if they
continue to suspect people who met
Russians or who talked about Trump's
business in Russia to suspect them of
crimes that means the whole story
continues and unfortunately this is true
you know immediately after the release
of the report we had the same stories in
the press mentioning again Michael Cohen
who who is now in jail in part because
he did not reveal all the details about
I'm quoting him you know discussing
gifting russia's President Vladimir
Putin and 50 million penthouse them then
it says the pardon of ultimate America
have rush to jump in here we've run out
of time this is it would be funny if it
weren't tragic here many thanks to my
guests here in Moscow London and in New
York and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here dartie see you next
time and remember crosstalk rules
[Music]
you